What I'd like to try, is for you guys to
tell me individually, what's more important to you to find out
from your genome? Would you be more interested in the
ancestry information, or the health information that it could give you.
Ginny, why don't you tell us, is there, is the one, more than the other?
>> Because Achondroplasia comes with the myriad of medical
complications, I would be more interested in the medical
>> Okay. Kagure?
>> I think it's medical.
I give medical maybe 60 per, 50, 80% and ancestry 20.
>> Okay.
>> I think it's medical, but it's really tough, because I am also very curious
about the ancestry. Particularly, particularly being Jewish,
and not being able to go back that far with the relatives who
came from Eastern Europe. Not being able to know who
these people were. Is, you know, kind of, if we could find something
out, that would be great.
>> For me, the ancestry is my, you know,
the first thing that makes me want to, the first
kind of information I want, and then the medical
would be something I would keep checking long term.
>> I guess mine would, would be the ancestry although the
medical is, is also important to me, but definitely the ancestry.
>> That means the information can actually change
anything, or is it just going to inform you?
>>
I definitely think it has the potential to change quite a bit. I mean
reconnecting with my biological parents is such an experience, that I think even
though I have my real parents now
that will always provide the support regardless
of me finding my biological parents. I
think having that connection, that new individual
in my life, will have a profound impact on me, as well as
the medical information, like it has the potential to have a profound impact.
>> What about you, Ryan? You think it
would change how you act, how you behave?
>> I don't think so. I think for me, it's more of just learning about me and
my personal, you know, my personal genetics and also
my ancestry. It's just more of a, you know,
it's a curiosity thing.
>> Carol?
>> Anxiety.
[LAUGH]
>> Causing more anxiety or less anxiety?
>> Causing more anxiety!
Not, of not knowing what's ahead. Of course, we don't know
anyway, but when there's some prediction that there's a possibility. And
understanding statistics and percentages, of possibilities that creates some
anxiety. but I can convince myself, that it's good to know and take action.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So I'm pragmatic,
but at the same time, it does produce a certain amount of anxiety for me.
>> Jenny?
>> I'm thinking about this question from the perspective of my average size
parents, and then 30 years later from me, when I was expecting a
child. And so they're two different things. I'm a mutation, so I came
out of, from nowhere, you know, unexpectedly with my parents. when they found
out, when the diagnosis was confirmed, I was 18
months old. And that allowed them, to just get right
on track with Little People of America, the national support
group finding the top orthopedic surgeons in the area. That
sort of thing. So I think that it was really
helpful for them. Of course I don't remember that, I
was 18 months old. as far as, you know, when
I was pregnant again, it goes back to knowing ahead
of time what, what was inside of me, and
what we had to prepare for was, was monumental.
>> Mm-hm.